today on the matt welsh show protests
are growing louder over the bill in
florida which bans the sexual
indoctrination of kids in elementary
school the left has managed to garner
this much outrage by simply lying about
what's in the bill so they will sift
through the nonsense and get to the
truth and we'll read the actual bill
itself which is a bold step if you can
imagine it also as gas prices skyrocket
across the country biden announces a
plan to ban russian oil but the new oil
import plan isn't much of an improvement
we'll talk about that camilla harris
also tries to be inspirational again and
it doesn't go well serena williams is
the victim of racism or so she claims a
police chief in florida is fired for
anti-white bias there's a new one in our
daily cancellation we'll talk about the
body positivity advocate who
inadvertently exposes an ugly truth
which is that the body positivity
movement is actually fueled by hatred
towards men i'll explain why all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now is the time to take advantage of low
mortgage rates before they're gone as
each day passes uh we don't you know
know exactly what to expect could they
drop a little bit maybe but it's not
worth it to wait and see you can lock
into a great deal right now by calling
american financing america's home for
home loans uh what you got to do is take
advantage of a free mortgage review and
see if you can save up to a thousand
dollars a month plus tens of thousands
long term because you know there's more
to a refinance than just a lower rate
but you are saving money the entire time
and with everything else going on right
now gas prices and everything else you
got to save money wherever you can you
can also shorten your term or pay off
high interest debt just be sure you act
soon the federal reserve meets late next
week and that can mean higher rates this
month you don't want to miss out on
what's available right now so you want
to act now act immediately and you can
do that by calling 866-569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls
182334 and
mlsconsumeraccess.org
the outrage in hysteria in florida over
the so-called don't say gay bill has
reached a fever pitch as the florida
senate began debating the legislation on
monday
um
though perhaps outrage and hysteria you
know is not exactly the right phrase
here in fact the the backlash is all
carefully scripted and cultivated um
some of the anger might be genuine i
don't know some of it a small portion of
it but even the genuine anger is rooted
in carefully disseminated propaganda and
everything else is just choreographed
nonsense
um we've seen plenty of false narratives
take hold before obviously there's a new
one every day somewhere as you know
every time a bell rings a false
narrative gets its wings in this country
but the pure
blatant falseness of this particular
false narrative manages to set itself
apart even amid the torrential downpour
of utter bullcrap from the media on a
daily basis
speaking of bull crap
saturday night live kicked things off
this week with another hilarious comedy
skit wherein no jokes were told nothing
funny happened
and kate mckinnon continued to prove
that probably christopher hitchens was
right about female comedians
anyway watch this
florida's controversial don't say gay
bill passed its final state senate
committee here to comment is kate
mckinnon
[Applause]
yeah i'm sorry to barge in here like out
of costume i just i heard about this law
and i j i think it's amazing
oh you you do
yeah because what you know when i was in
middle school in the 90s
i was some
i was kind of like tortured by the
constant use of the word gay like you
know that's so gay or ooh you're gay it
just it made me feel horrible and to
hear that ron desantis
has has taken a stand and said no
you cannot say gay in school anymore
i'm just like i'm so jazzed and in
florida of all places
[Music]
i mean
yeah
yeah so actually i feel like there's
been a misunderstanding so
the law actually means that you can't
acknowledge that gay exists at all
[Music]
can we all just stop pretending this
woman is funny can we at least do that
we agree on that as a society i don't
believe that people actually find her
funny at all
and every year she has a new impression
everyone says have you seen the kate
mckinnon
impression of uh hillary clinton it's
just her it's just her being herself
which is which is very unfunny this is
also the one i think mckinnon wasn't she
the one who did the uh
after hillary clinton lost uh she she
did the she she played the piano while
crying
um you know as hillary clinton and then
she sang hallelujah or something like
that i think i'm pretty sure that was
her anyway
she says
what that's a good question because
everything that scarlett johansson's
henpecked husband just said there was
totally false
but you wouldn't know that if you listen
to the protesters who have been in
tallahassee
screaming about a fictional bill that
stops them from saying the word gay in
school i mean people actually believe
this this is what this is what people
believe that there's a
there's a bill in florida that says
you're simply not allowed to say the
word gay ever in in any school in
florida um
floridapolitics.com has the report on
what these protesters are doing it says
a group of florida students took to the
capitol steps in tallahassee monday
morning in a last-ditch peel a plea
rather with state senators to vote down
a controversial measure dubbed the don't
say gay bill by its critics students
chanted we say gay and planned sit-in
protests throughout the day as the
senate prepares to take up the
controversial hb 1557 which proponents
say would bolster parental rights but
opponents say it would create a
dangerous environment for students
our students have no choice but to be
here transgender educator cyrus bresek
said
their lives are being politicized
they're being actively threatened and
our classrooms are being set up as the
traps
meanwhile democrats in florida have been
comporting themselves
with all the dignity that you might
expect um let's see what they're up to
down there
[Music]
yes that's right uh democrats are now at
the point where they're literally just
running through the halls shouting the
word gay this is all they have to offer
the world this is their whole party in a
nutshell this is this is all they got
they have nothing to say but gay and
they say it all the time everywhere
feeling little need to say any other
words in between that word so i
appreciate how they're just cutting to
the chase now at least down in florida
stop pretending that you have anything
else just just repeat the word over and
over again because that's all you got
this is all the democrat party is now
you can tell why so many democrats were
disappointed with joe biden's state of
the union address it was a horrible
speech but that wasn't the problem for
them all they wanted him to do was stand
there for 90 minutes and just say the
word gay over and over again gay gay did
i mention gay also trans trans and gay
and gay and trans the state of the union
is super gay
that's what they wanted to hear now
given that this is literally all
democrats have to say or offer um you
can see why they'd treat any bill
preventing them from saying the word gay
as the apocalypse because that means
that they can't speak anymore they can't
say anything if they can't say the word
gay
the only problem is that no such bill
exists
but that didn't stop the left from
demanding that every corporation in
existence denounce the bill and many
have but uh disney had remained
conspicuously silent up until now and
and pressure continued to mount because
disney of course they're down there in
florida and um and so the left was
saying this this is what we see of
course is anytime the left's upset about
something
um they're not just going to be upset
about it themselves they need everyone
else to also be upset about it
and um and they needed disney to be
upset about it finally bob chappie who's
the new ceo of disney
sent out a memo to staff saying on
friday i met with a small group of
disney lgbtq plus leaders to discuss
controversial legislation pending in
florida that would impact their
communities i want to thank them for a
meaningful illuminating and at times
deeply moving conversation i told the
group i would write to the entire
company with my thoughts on the issues
we discussed i wish every one of our
employees could have heard not just the
passionate voices in the room but the
bravery honesty and pride those voices
expressed it is a conversation i will
never forget i want to be crystal clear
i and the entire leadership team
unequivocally stand in support of our
lgbtq plus employees their families and
their communities and etc and so forth
blah blah blah now
and he goes on for for like pages and
pages about how awesome and wonderful
and beautiful and uh courageous
lgbt people are but that wasn't enough
of course
you know even that was not enough
old bob should have just sent a memo
with the word gay written ten thousand
times and instead he used other words
besides that and that has led disney
employees to now speak out in anger
which is something that we've seen you
know we saw this with with netflix now
we're sitting with disney one of them is
gay disney animator um a guy named ben
seaman
who posted a now viral video calling out
his employer listen
anytime you're different in school
you're probably prone to get picked on
and you're searching for answers
wondering if there is something wrong
with you and luckily i had a teacher
that was very kind and talked to me
about it and let me know that there
wasn't anything wrong with being gay and
it made a huge impact on my life
if the don't say gay bill passes in
florida that would have never happened
to me i would have been a left alone and
scared and lgbt kids are going to be
left alone and scared and hurt by this
bill
and teachers that are gay and married to
partners won't even be able to talk
about them they're going to have to
pretend that lgbtq people don't even
exist this bill is going to hurt kids i
love working for disney i've loved
working for disney it's an amazing
company that i loved since i was a kid
and they make amazing movies and
television specials and they're starting
to include more lgbt characters that let
kids know that you know if being gay is
all right but when they have donated to
the sponsors and co-sponsors of the
don't say gay bill and they have made no
position against this bill and they are
going to continue donating to these
politicians they are essentially saying
that this bill is okay
oh yes the famously anti-gay disney you
know disney which which puts uh four gay
people and seven trans people in every
single movie or tv show they make now is
uh as we all know i mean they're they're
secretly
very anti-gay these are these are
right-wing social conservative
extremists now i understand this is
something of a moot point to the people
disseminating this narrative but i do
feel behooved to mention that that that
nothing
uh seaman said there bears any relation
to the truth whatsoever seaman was
completely wrong um but they didn't look
he didn't just pull this out of thin air
this has been the result of a wildly
successful branding campaign
by the lgbt left including organizations
like equality florida which put out this
ad um about the bill a few months ago
watch this
all right chelsea you're up
[Music]
tell us about your hero
i have two heroes
my two moms
[Music]
it's okay you should be proud
go ahead
mrs thompson please report to the front
office
so there you go um according to equality
florida no child at any age can even so
much as mention gayness even when
discussing their own families
or an alarm will go off and their
teacher will be immediately fired so
there's
they're monitoring the classroom and
there's some sort of sensor and if you
say the word gay an alarm goes off now
when i am theocratic fascist dictator of
a country we may have policies like that
in schools but right now nothing like
that is being proposed and also of
course there's a sign that will hang in
every classroom saying state approved
topics only of course that part is
actually true in a sense because public
schools are government schools
so i like how they put that there like
it's something sinister well state
approved topics only every topic is
state approved
the schools are run by the state after
all
but the rest is of course horse manure
and to prove that i need only do
something completely radical
um that will seem radical anyway
and that is that is to refer to the text
of the actual bill itself
now the first thing you'll notice when
you uh actually read the don't say gay
bill if you do read it which of course
none of the critics have is that the
word gay does not appear anywhere within
the bill now you might wonder
how a bill can forbid a word from being
spoken without mentioning the word that
it is for build forbidding that doesn't
really make a lot of sense right
well it can't and this bill doesn't
here's what this bill does say okay i'm
gonna read it to it says
classroom instruction by school
personnel or third parties on sexual
orientation or gender identity may not
occur in kindergarten through grade 3 or
in a manner that is not age appropriate
or developmentally appropriate for
students in accordance with state
standards
so this is classroom instruction
by school personnel
um
and it's specifically we're talking
about kindergarten through grade three
three
that's it okay that's the relevant
portion of the bill it specifically
targets very young students pre-k
through third grade and only forbids the
teachers from instructing the kids
about sexual orientation and gender
identity it does not at all restrict
what the students say
and it doesn't restrict what the
teachers can say aside from official
classroom instruction in other words
there's nothing in the spill preventing
a child from mentioning their gay
parents
or or even preventing a teacher from
mentioning their gay partner though i'm
not sure why teachers would need to be
having those conversations with students
anyway
but there's nothing in the bill that at
any point that has ever targeted that or
that would ever prevent that
um bill has nothing to do with it it
only restricts classroom instruction by
preventing lessons about gender identity
and sexual orientation
for for kids who are eight years old or
younger
so the real problem with this bill and i
have a problem with it too the real
problem is that it only pertains to kids
that young it should go this should this
should apply to all grades
because there's no grade or age where
it's necessary or appropriate for
teachers to instruct kids about these
topics
you know the the the florida gop they
basically extended an olive branch to
the left by limiting
um the scope of the bill in this
arbitrary way and as expected
the left took the olive branch poured
lighter fluid on it and set it on fire
that's the way it always goes they're
not interested in any kind of
um
compromise
now you thought that that oh they'd be
okay with it because like obviously any
rational sane person would be okay with
saying that we're not gonna instruct
about sexual orientation or gender
identity to people to kids in third
grade or younger
and so you you try to keep it there and
limit it
and you figure well no one could have a
problem with that of course they have a
problem with that
what's actually happening here
in reality
as the bill only forbids the sexual
indoctrination of very young children we
could see again that democrats are are
so desperate
to sexually indoctrinate and groom young
children that anything preventing them
from doing so is like the apocalypse
and actually this is the worst thing you
could do they might actually be a little
bit less upset
if you only forbid it from let's say
uh
8th grade through 12th grade
you know if you hit middle school and
and high school
i think they'd probably be less upset
because they know
that if they want to get in there and
brainwash kids
the easiest and best time to do it for
them is at the youngest possible ages
um they and they truly believe
that they have a right to do it not just
that they're right in doing it but they
also have a right to do it
not just that they will or that they
want to but they feel entitled to
because they're predators and liars and
we don't need to be on defense about
this
they're the ones who are openly in favor
of grooming children
and are filled with satanic fury when
you try to prevent it
and that's why we should oppose them
with every fiber of our being now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right first of all uh happy
international what is a woman day i i
wanted to uh it is international women's
day by the way i don't know if you if
you uh have celebrated yet but i wanted
to extend the offer that um i put out
there on twitter this morning because
i'm getting increasingly desperate and
so this is a real offer i'm i'm offering
this i will give 10 million dollars
in honor of
what is a international women's day i
will give 10 million dollars to any
leftist who could define the word woman
today
10 million it's on the table not
literally
offer subject to change without notice
but that's what i'm that's what i'm
putting on the table
just just one for international women's
day can you do it
we'll see um i'll let you know if anyone
comes through now this is from the daily
wire says the national average price of
gasoline set a new all-time record on
monday blowing past the previous record
that was set more than a decade ago 2008
gas buddy reported the national average
price of gasoline in the us today broke
the existing record rewriting the
all-time high to today's four dollars
it's about you know 4.1 per gallon uh
the previous all-time high was set back
in 2008
um just ahead of the u.s great recession
and housing crisis so there's some good
news
gas buddy a platform that collects data
on fuel prices to save consumers money
added that the price of diesel was
likely to break the record
um of 4.8 per gallon in the next two
weeks
and that's where we are with gases and
it's there's there's no
sign of it of any improvement you know
oftentimes we had these big spikes and
they go back down but we could be
looking at this for days weeks months
who knows maybe even longer
um and this raises a lot of questions a
lot of people have questions and jen
pasake was asked about gas prices and uh
i don't think her answer was very
helpful but here's what she said
yesterday
um i want to read to you if i could jen
some comments from people we've met at
gas stations today
one woman saying i just never imagined
to see the cost of gas be this high
another said it's a huge stressor to my
financial situation a huge stressor it's
kind of like something i've stressed
about like during the day will i be able
to afford guests how much money do i
have
what is the white house what is the
president's message to americans who are
going to the gas station today and
seeing prices so high
well the president's message is that he
is going to do everything we can
everything he can to reduce the impact
on the american people including the
price of gas at the tank what is also
true is that because of the actions of
president putin because he invaded a
sovereign country that created
instability in the markets that is
something the president talked about
even before
russia and president putin move forward
with their actions but we have already
taken steps the president has already
taken steps historic release from the
strategic petroleum reserve one that's
done in a coordinated fashion and
clearly we will continue to have
conversations with large oil producers
and suppliers around the world about how
to mitigate the impact and and consider
domestic options as well
now a day after
this
that answer was given it was announced
that the by administration will be
banning russian oil so this they they
are going to be banning imports of
russian oil
the 600 000 or so barrels
a day that we bring in
are now we're not going to be bringing
in
and this is something that a lot of
people have called for
uh and it's if you're if you're gonna
try to hurt putin this would be the way
to do it rather than you know getting
rid of your russian vodka which probably
isn't even russian that you already
bought
this will be the way to do it the
problem is well now okay you're gonna
get rid of the russian oil we're gonna
we're not gonna import any russian oil
well what are we gonna replace it with
because that is it's
certainly not
it's not as though the majority of our
oil we got from russia majority we get
from canada but if you're not going to
be bringing that oil in you got to get
it from somewhere else
one idea would be to get it from
underneath our own ground but they don't
want to do that so instead
what it what it looks like according to
new york times and their report
yesterday we're going to be replacing
that with more exports from venezuela
so venezuela is also a socialist
dictator state and also an ally
of of russia so it sort of makes you
think we might as well stick with what
we already have if we're going to be
doing that
so instead of russian oil now we're just
going to be importing more venezuelan
oil
here's the other thing we have to
realize is that the has the high gas
prices are a feature right not a bug
as far as the bite administration is
concerned
you know they're not they are going to
be careful about coming out and saying
it p buddha just has all but said that
himself
but it's not something they're going to
going to say explicitly
um other people on the left
have been more explicit about this
there were some there was some
left-wing author on twitter it kind of
went viral yesterday because he said
that hey you know if you're
if you're using 20 or 30 gallons a week
then then there's there's a problem
anyway you know the problem is you
so now this is someone that's the case
for a lot of people on the left they're
they live in the city
and uh they ride their little bikes to
work if they even go to work or they
take an uber and they're they're shocked
to learn that not everyone lives in the
city they're actually there's actually
this whole
there's really the majority of the
country geographically that that is not
comprised of major cities and people
live spread out and so they have to
drive a lot and they're very shocked to
learn this
um
but from the left-wing mentality first
of all
you know they live in big
metropolitan environments
if you live out in the country then
you're probably a backwards redneck
anyway so they don't care about you and
also um this is all it's all part of the
transformation right
this is this is a that i think that's
the exact word that pete buddha just
used last week this is a transformative
moment
really this is an advantage to have high
gas prices because it's going to
encourage people to stop driving cars so
that we can
end climate change we all stop driving
cars and climate the climate won't
change anymore
it'll be 65 degrees and sunny with a
slight breeze for everybody for all time
well there'll be no more climate change
that's what they're that's what they're
working towards
and so if it seems like the biot
administration is not
actually despite what gen pasake claims
not actually doing a whole lot
to solve the gas prices problems because
they don't really have any motivation to
solve it
um staying on the same subject and with
the same administration camilla harris
was
talking about some of this and energy
and climate change and she tried to be
inspirational
once again and this is always a problem
now the good news is she's on script she
didn't go off script
but the script itself needs a little bit
of work listen to this
imagine a future
the freight trucks that deliver bread
and milk to our grocery store shelves
and the buses that take children to
school and parents to work imagine all
the heavy-duty vehicles that keep our
supply lines strong and allow our
economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it
that's why we're here today
because we have the ability to see what
can be
unburdened by what has been
and then to make the possible
actually happen
we have the we have the advantage to see
what can be
unburdened by what has been
and then make the possible
actually happen
like she was going given for a little
bit of a rhyme there i don't know
uh the problem with camille harris is
she's a terrible orator
she's a terrible public speaker
but it's the worst combination
now it's what most people are bad public
speakers and it's fine they know that
they're bad and it's fine you know
because it's just you're just like
everybody else you're terrible
but she is a bad public speaker and she
thinks she's good she thinks that she's
one of the great orders of uh in modern
american history and so you could tell
just the confidence with which she
utters
this kind of just utter this this total
vapid meaningless nonsense it's the
confidence that really makes it all all
the more cringy speaking of meaningless
statements again from the daily wire it
says hollywood actor couple nick
offerman and megan mulally told russian
president vladimir putin to f off and go
home while the duo hosted the 2022
independent spirit awards now it's
pretty courageous
um
this according to hollywood reporter on
sunday it says after returning from a
commercial break the co-host took a
moment to show their solidarity with and
support for ukraine offerman began by
telling the audience that they'd like to
send best wishes to those affected by
the war in ukraine and all unjust
conflicts around the world and they said
i think we speak for everyone here when
we say we're hoping for a quick and
peaceful resolution specifically f off
and go home putin and the whole audience
applauded and they all started uh
lifting their middle fingers
and um to the camera
i i think i think we could all agree
incredible incredible courage by these
hollywood actors in hollywood
to really come out and make it known
that they don't like putin
you know they're really putting
themselves in a position i think uh to
get a lot of criticism from the heavy
pro-putin faction in hollywood and then
also they may have actually solved the
problem you know i don't know if putin
has seen this yet i'm not sure if he's
aware if anyone's told him
but the moment that he sees that nick
offerman at the spirit awards in
hollywood um told him to go home i think
there's a very good chance that putin
will say well all right
okay and then just and and then the war
will end
um and there were a lot of other really
inspiring moments like kristen stewart
stewart by the way another actress uh
she joined in the middle finger and then
she took the stage and had had her own
speech about uh the ukraine conflict
because these are the people that we go
to
for this sort of thing and here's what
she had to say
we stand for independence as a community
we stand for freedom of expression we
stand for humanity
today we are compelled to stand with the
people of ukraine who are yeah
they
i'm gonna try to say this right they are
risking their lives to fight for those
very things
we stand with the hundreds of thousands
of refugees fleeing this war both
ukrainians and those of other
ethnicities and nationalities who are
being denied safe harbor
yeah
we must never
let's glob that's weird
um
we must never ever take for granted the
importance of courage empathy and the
power
of connecting
the power of understanding each other
feels really good
so let's give it a shot
wow
a lot of insight there a lot of courage
a lot of insight
um
like you i turn to kristen stewart in
times like this
i don't know what's going on in the
world i don't know what to think i'm
scared i'm alone i'm nervous
and i just want to know that kristen
stewart is on top of it and i'm looking
to her as a guiding light to show me the
way forward
um so just a lot a lot of great courage
and a beautiful moment there at the
spirit awards whatever the hell the
spirit awards are all right this is also
from the daily wire it says a fort
lauderdale florida police chief was
fired after an investigation stated that
he had asked which one is blacker when
considering a promotion and also
allegedly pointed to photographs on a
conference room of the department's
command staff saying that wall is two
whites and i'm gonna change that
former uh fort lauderdale police chief
larry siroto 48 the first openly gay
police chief hired in fort lauderdale
was fired last thursday after bias
complaints filed last october with the
equal with the u.s equal employment
opportunity commission prompted
that that prompted an investigation two
police officers said they had been
denied promotions based on race sexual
orientation and gender city manager
chris lagerbloom
informed the police department he would
freeze all promotions until further
notice to address concerns surrounding
the recent police department promotions
that's a really interesting story
because you don't often hear about um
people in these positions getting fired
for anti-white bias i mean it almost
never happens
and you could point out that what what
this police chief was saying that we
need to be blacker that well that's too
white too many white candidates that's
that's like the official policy
in many states in many of these
institutions including academic
including academia that's what
affirmative action is
and it's also discriminatory and racist
but he came out and said and some
employees actually had the the courage i
think the real courage here given the
backlash that they could have
experienced
had the courage to go
to
not accept that
and they went to the equal rights
commission and reported this
because this is racial bias
and this is exactly what needs to happen
you know i've made this exact point
about employees at these woke companies
who are forced to sit for
crt training where they're singled out
by race and told that if you're white
hear all the bad things about you
and here's what you need to say if
you're white here's what you need to
think and believe
and you know even in some cases having
these uh indoctrination sessions the
brainwashing sessions where only white
people are required to attend i mean
that sort of thing
that is
blatant discrimination your the law
actually forbids that
okay now i'm sure the left democrats
they they would like to change the law
to explicitly allow for
um
anti-white racism in these contexts
but as of right now they haven't done it
so
we do we do have equal rights laws
which if you if you read the way the
laws are written
it says that you're not allowed to
single anybody out for harassment
negative treatment or anything like that
based on their race
and the way the law is written it
doesn't say as long as they're black it
just says based on race
the companies get away with it because
they're really hardly ever sued for it
these things are not reported
and the employees just kind of sit there
and endure it
and maybe they'll take
pictures and they'll put it on twitter
and it'll go viral and people complain
about it and that's fine like what
happened with uh what was it coca-cola i
mean there's been a bunch of companies
and sure go ahead and do that but then
sue them
for rate for illegal racial
discrimination against you as a white
employee
so that's real racism let's go to some
fake racism i just wanted to mention
this serena williams is
a wildly successful and famous athlete
she's got she's she's worth i'm sure
hundreds of millions of dollars they
just made a movie about her
she's just
celebrated and loved and everything
but she is still a victim so the new
york times did a story about serena
williams and in the print version
apparently there still is a print
version so that's the real headline news
to me in the print version they
apparently
put a picture with the story that was
not serena williams it was her i think
her sister it was the wrong picture
and these kinds of mistakes happen right
um
and but serena williams
was not willing to just say okay well
mistakes happen who cares
i mean everyone knows who i am i don't
have to worry that i'm being erased here
people are going to forget what i look
like
she couldn't do that so instead she
sends out a tweet no matter how far we
come we get reminded that it's not
enough this is why i raised 111 million
dollars for serena ventures to support
the founders who are overlooked by
ingrained systems woefully unaware of
their biases
because even i am overlooked you could
do better
yes even serena williams is overlooked
serena williams who
they did the article about her
okay serena you the article was about
you you're overlooked in an article
about you
one of the hundreds of articles that
have been written about you through your
career
i'm being overlooked i'm a victim of
racism
this is this is what the
racial indoctrination on the left get
gets you it's just
you end up with people who are totally
unwilling to just look looking for every
possible slight
and totally unwilling to extend any
grace whatsoever
always assuming the worst possible
motivations
okay in the world of the race hustler
um there are no innocent mistakes there
are no oversights
there's
nothing inconvenient can happen to you
that is not
grounded in racism
so serena williams another
another victim we should all apologize
to her for this horrible life that we
forced her to live as a
multi-millionaire athlete let's get down
to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right uh dailywire.com sweet baby
comments by the way if you are watching
this
uh show right now on youtube or on the
daily wire um i hope that you are
inspired by what you've been witnessing
throughout the course of the show and
that is this ongoing battle with my
earpiece that i've been waging so this
is this is also you know we talked about
the example of heroism among athletes um
i think you you quite often get heroism
and examples of courage on this show
like right now for example
because this is a real this is a real
annoyance that i'm
that i have to point out and complain
about so i guess i lose all the credit
that i would otherwise get so we've got
a few uh video comments here let's go to
clip 14.
hey matt walsh to play devil's advocate
for the tick tock mom i can kind of see
where she's coming from my husband and i
had our first baby last year and we were
so excited at the prospect of finally
getting to tell our friends and family
that our baby had finally been born we
also did not know what gender our child
was when we were pregnant so we wanted
to have the joy of saying we had a boy
or we had a girl
fun fact did you know that baby boys and
baby girls are actually born with
different body parts and you can tell
right away at birth if you've had a boy
or a girl you don't even have to wait
until they're three or four years old to
tell you what gender they are you know
right off the bat it's amazing
anyway we didn't want our friends and
family to find out about that happy news
via someone else's facebook post about
our baby
so we wanted to have that joy secondly
regarding photos of the baby on social
media i can see where she's coming from
on that too there are so many creeps and
crazies and sickos out there i do not
want those sickos having access to
photos of my kids so for that reason we
don't post pictures of our kids really
online and we prefer that others do too
so when we would text photos we just say
hey we don't post these online so we'd
prefer a few not either
and finally about texting during labor
i don't know about anyone else's
experience but when i was in labor
my husband and i we were a little busy a
little preoccupied and we really didn't
care if our phone was buzzing with all
of these texts coming through as i said
we were a little busy so those texts
just went unanswered and it's okay
not to instantly respond to every text
message the second it comes through to
your phone let me just jump in let me
i'm going to cut you off and uh do a
little mansplaining here okay because
this is what men always do uh
no i look i i get it she's talking about
the tick tock mom who had the whole list
of rules because she was having a baby
and so there's a whole list of rules for
her friends and family
uh of things that they're allowed to do
and not allowed to do we we've seen this
as i said this is the kind of mentality
we see with weddings all the time with
the
infamous cliched bridezilla sort of
thing and now it's made its way into
other life events because
for the uh narcissistic
people in our country
you know for them they can experience a
life event that billions of other people
have experienced but when they
experience it suddenly it is it is
imbued with significance that it's never
had before and that gives you the right
to be just a a total tyrant about it
um and like i understand some of the
reasons for the rules you don't want the
pictures up you don't want people to
spoil the news you want to be able to
announce it to yourself but can i just
say
like
what about this for an option just just
relax okay
sometimes you just have to let
you you can't control everything that
people do and you just have to relax a
little bit and if i'm the one telling
you that then you know you should listen
because i'm not exactly great at
relaxing like right now for example this
earpiece i'm just gonna rip it out
because it's driving me insane okay josh
hopkins says
good there we go i'm free josh hopkins
says governor cox has been doing stuff
like this for a while now in utah no
idea if he's a coward or a woke idiot uh
neither or are okay well i don't know i
have to choose between the two coward or
woke idiot i mean
i i think that they quite often go hand
in hand but i i think the answer is
coward of course because a woke idiot
would mean that he actually
is a is a
you know a leftist radical himself and
actually believes
uh that men are women and women are men
and that there's no difference between
the two and that there's nothing unfair
about men competing against women that
would make him a woke idiot and i'm
quite sure that's not the case um so
it's possible to be both a coward and
awoken in this case he's just a coward
he knows that it's wrong he absolutely
knows it
and um and yet is going along with it
anyway
uh let's see
king ginger says i think you're
absolutely right about the american
convoy the only reason the canadian
convoy was such a success at least not
optically was because it happened in
canada not even their government
suspected that that many people
would be against their mandates and
covert policies even if it didn't
succeed in their ultimate goal which was
to have the mandates taken away
completely it exposed just how
dictatorial trudeau is and how their
government is not like america's yeah i
think you raise a good point about one
of the difference between the canadian
convoy and the american convoy the
american convoy by the way i don't even
know
they were going to circle the beltway
all week and i'm not even sure if they
were out there on the beltway this week
at all
and if they were then they've just been
swallowed by the traffic and they're not
really causing any inconvenience at all
which which is good for the people other
people on the beltway but then that even
more raises the question of what's what
is the point at all now you're just
you're just driving around in the
traffic for a week uh what is that
supposed to prove but i think one of the
key differences is the one you point out
that
you know because with a with a protest
um you're sending a message or there's
there's a certain goal you have in mind
you're trying to push
a certain agenda forward but you're also
it's also about raising awareness okay
and in this case for a lot of people
in canada with the trucker convoy
i think it raised awareness to the fact
that there are a whole lot of canadians
who are not okay with the coveted
tyranny okay it was a way for canadians
in general to speak out against it and
that was actually a revelation to a lot
of people especially in america
including myself because prior to this i
kind of thought well it seems like most
canadians are on board with this
and that wasn't the case at all um
but in america we we obviously
know that a great many of us are not
okay with it we've been very vocal about
that the entire time
so
doesn't mean you don't speak out against
it but it just again
underscores why um
these two things are different
um
let's see
another comment says i love how the room
is decorated with the walrus book
that book has a name
and it's johnny the walrus how dare you
you're banned from the show
uh
and let's see drake says matt would you
be on board for cancelling the portion
of the student debt that is a byproduct
of compound interest
i mean are we canceling interest on uh
compound or not are we canceling the
interest on other debt as well you know
i i don't think so and my answer to that
is no
no i'm i'm in favor
of cancelling these student loans and
the compound interest and everything
else
um i'm in favor of canceling it going
forward
sort of proactively going forward
by
more and more people choosing not to
take the loans out
so that is a version of cancelling
student loan debt that i'm in favor of
you can cancel it
you know if you are a
for your own kids and for this young
generation we could cancel it by going
forward
by encouraging people to make other
choices
aside from at the age of 18 or 19 going
in taking out this big loan
and consigning themselves to
you know decades of debt for an
education that will not be worth it at
all
and
one other comment says uh rochelle says
i would like to say i disagree with
today's cancellation i'm personally
against protesting in general of any
kind um i know you ask why now but i
respond to say why not yes the mandates
are being lifted because the left knows
a red wave is coming but it's
embarrassing that canadian truckers made
a stance before we americans did
chuckers play a huge role in our lives
and no most of them don't have degrees
or may not have even attended college
but after the canadian trucker convoy
truckers realized
their value in logistics for this
country and now and how valuable their
services are i could go outside and hold
up a sign protesting mandates and that
would be theater but if truckers stop on
the highway i wouldn't be able to
purchase a sign to hold up so give them
some credit
uh first of all i don't think it's true
that
the people in canada made a stand before
americans did i mean i think there were
a lot of americans taking a stand
against this from the very beginning
i mean from almost from day one there
were for example pastors not enough of
them granted but pastors getting
arrested because they refused to go
along with their shirts but their
churches being shut down so there have
been americans taking a stance i don't
think that's exactly true
um as far as the power that truckers
have i totally agree with you
um but i don't think you're exercising
that power in a meaningful
way by just driving around on the on the
beltway um as i've said this this entire
time i think if if truckers have
specific grievances
that they want to get across
and i can certainly imagine that they
would
maybe the best way to get it across is
rather than driving around the beltway
is to is to go on strike is to refuse to
haul the freight in the first place or
how about a more targeted thing i've
been told you know i'm talking about how
the mandates are going away and i'm
constantly reminded oh that's not the
case so what about in california they
still have mandates i think the mandates
are even going away in california but
okay let's take california for example
if there's something going on in
california
that truckers don't like well then how
about a protest where they say we're not
gonna haul freight in california until
this goes away whatever it is
now there's a protest
that
would certainly send the message
and it would also put the left in a
position of being against people who are
workers blue-collar workers going on
strike and i realize the left has no
problem being hypocritical and so
they'll take that position fine but it
just further exposes the hypocrisy if
you have workers striking
and the left is against them so there's
a protest i would support well if you
haven't already added the premiere of
the daily wires latest film the
hyperions to your to-do list this week
then i suggest you do so right now
because the film premieres this thursday
night march 10th and we cannot wait to
share it with you it's exactly what
entertainment in hollywood is missing
these days it's not woke it has zero
underlying political agenda it's just
about
entertainment you know because when it
comes to entertainment that's really all
that matters is that it's fun that it's
enjoyable and this movie certainly is
check out the trailer
[Music]
my name is vista mandelbaum
my brother and i have taken four
hostages everybody against the wall
we've come for one thing
our titan badges
is this real yes ma'am this is real
well i want that too
it's the police they want to talk to
whoever's in charge
this titan badge can grant an individual
superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
meet apollo
i'd recommend next time using your power
yeah i mean yeah if you think so
calling all hyperions
on my way
you're making such a mess in here
we've got a hyperion in roots not a good
time to look stupid
shots fired
god come on give me my gun
suit up for adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
next question how's the family the
family is um
gosh what is it
marvelous
[Music]
the hyperions is a dysfunctional family
film with throwback vibes and it's 100
worth the stream we'll be streaming um
the film once on march 10th for all of
youtube to see but this is the last time
we're going to be streaming the film on
youtube for all the free loaders out
there which means that you can still
watch the movies but you got to go to
dailywire.com subscribe and become a
member today and get access to all of
the content we have going on uh and uh
coming up and also you know it's um
always a good time i think for new
voices to enter into the conversation um
into the transgender conversation
especially because as you know um as i'm
constantly preaching about diversity is
extremely important to me and that is
ultimately why i decided to write the
best-selling children's lgbtq plus book
johnny the walrus which you can see on
display behind me in the hotel room and
if you have not
yet purchased the literary sensation of
2022 and i think probably of the decade
then you can do that go to amazon
and or you can go to johnnywalrus.com
and get your copy that way now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel another tick tock
personality was also a body positivity
advocate
mallory burgess describes herself as an
exercise physiologist and these days has
cultivated a pretty decent following of
social media where she criticizes
so-called diet culture and calls out fat
shaming and tries to explode the myth
um that as she puts it weight can be
easily controlled what's interesting
about ms burgess is that according to my
brief google search anyway like for two
seconds
her own backstory completely undermines
her current stance on the supposed myth
of weight loss in fact the first thing
that popped up
when i when i went on google and i was
trying to figure out who this person is
so i can cancel them um the first thing
that popped up was a headline in the
baltimore sun from 2014 and this was the
headline
mcdaniel student loses half her body
weight
the article tells us about a mallory
burgess who was so heavy that she
couldn't fit into restaurant booths she
said but now that is in 2014 now she
lost over 150 pounds and found a new
lease on life fast forward to 2022
and here's what she is now saying
what is something you used to strongly
believe in that you no longer believe in
at all that body weight is something you
can easily change and control
oh look another random person on tick
tock making outrageous claims with no
sources to make them feel better about
their choices
no
andrew i read you know all those
peer-reviewed studies that you never
actually read in your sophomore year
college class
i read those for my job and there is a
growing body of research on weight and
body size that is emerging within the
last five years that's finding a lot of
it is genetically predetermined that all
it takes is for one low chromosome to
get a mutation and oops that person puts
on weight very easily or can't put
weight on at all and sure some of those
factors are external but not nearly as
much as the diet industry will lead you
to believe you know that billion dollar
industry whose primary interest is
making sure that you keep hating
yourself so you'll keep giving them
money maybe it's time to shift our
narrative
yes i mean how could anyone think that
people can lose weight just by eating
less
i mean
i know why you should think that malory
given that you did that exact thing
and even without your personal history
it should still be obvious that weight
can be controlled maybe not easily
controlled okay so that's where that's
where you get us on the technicality
it's not easy in the sense that
self-discipline isn't necessarily easy
but it can be simply controlled though
so let's just call it that
as i mentioned last week i just read a
book called in the heart of the sea
about a group of 19th century whalers
who were shipwrecked in the middle of
the pacific that's a great book by the
way most of them died of starvation a
few survived the survivors when they
were finally rescued were gaunt and
skeletal there was no obesity among them
in fact there has never been an obese
shipwreck survivor rescued after months
at sea or stranded on an island not one
in history why is that because they
don't have a lot to eat and when you eat
less you lose weight that's the
correlation now i'm not suggesting that
people should starve themselves i'm
merely pointing out the calories you
consume do indeed have a direct and
quite predictable impact on your weight
if weight was purely genetic
then there should be
lots of morbid obesity even in places
where people don't have a lot to eat and
yet when you look at this map for
example a map of
obesity rates by country
it shows that what a coincidence the
countries that have the most to eat and
where people tend to be the most
sedentary also have the most obesity
36 percent united states is obese
in tanzania it's nine percent indonesia
seven percent
isn't that quite an amazing anomaly
all of the purples the rates between 0
and 10
are all concentrated in the third world
while the highest rates are all in the
first world
how do you explain that do they not have
the fat gene down there in mozambique
we have all the fat genes here and all
the fast food talk about bad luck
but this is um this is all academic
mallory has a more recent video that
raises i think some more interesting
points
um well the video doesn't really raise
interesting points but interesting
points can be raised in response to it
so here you go
a little psa for the girlies that hop on
this app and do like the latest gross
weekly body checking trend or do a what
i eat in a day and flash their abs or
just generally fish for compliments that
they are in fact not fat come here
stop doing free labor for the patriarchy
the hierarchy of bodies where one is
considered the best that was designed by
men maybe you've noticed that
heterosexual men have an incredibly
narrow definition of what's attractive
and heterosexual women have like a much
broader one
that's by design if your feminism does
not include fighting fat phobia and body
liberation it's not [ __ ] feminism
that shit's just another wing of the
patriarchy babes and there might come a
day where you
gain weight
and you're still gonna need feminism
then because if you think men are awful
when you're thin
oof i got really bad news for you you
don't need to trash other body types to
make you feel good about yourself
okay
first of all
the patriarchy
she says that you know they're doing
free labor for the patriarchy i want to
be clear the patriarchy does not expect
women to do free labor
we will happily pay you 70 cents for
every dollar a man earns second
you notice how how people are who are
not thin
always feel entitled to tell people who
are thin how they should and shouldn't
feel about their bodies so for all the
talk about fat shaming the fact is the
only kind of socially acceptable body
shaming that you ever encounter in our
culture today is the kind you just heard
in that video
third most importantly here's a point
that i've been wanting to make for a
while and um and our friend mallory has
given me the opening
much of this body positivity stuff is
very thinly veiled misinjury okay the
body positivity people most of them
really just hate men
and i don't mean that they hate men just
because the body positivity stuff is
never meant to encourage men but only
women
all of the fat people we're supposed to
celebrate are women all of them
and that's true but that's not why i'm
saying this i'm saying it because of of
what she just said people like mallory
don't like the traditional feminine form
because for one thing
it takes some work to maintain and
they're too lazy and second because
that's the the form that men prefer
so she says with disdain that men have a
very narrow conception of what they find
attractive as opposed to women who are
more expansive
now the second part of that isn't really
true just ask any out-of-shape single
guy with no money
how easy it is to find a woman who will
give him the time of day he probably is
not going to think that women are all
that open-minded when it comes to their
attractions that's not going to be his
lived experience
no women broadly speaking look for
certain things in men men look for
certain things in women the things they
look for are different
and the way they look for those things
is also different because men are much
more visual by nature but it's not
accurate to say that one group is more
enlightened than the other now we're
speaking in general terms here again but
it's certainly it's certainly not
accurate generally to say
that
men want women who look gaunt and
famished
that was a trend on the fashion runways
for a while if any men were responsible
for that it would have been gay men not
heterosexuals we had nothing to do with
that that's not what we're after
men like all of the things that
everybody already knows thinner waist
curvier hips longer legs obviously men
are attracted to breasts to the feminine
form in other words
men are also attracted to things that
are perhaps um noticed on a more
subconscious level like facial symmetry
though women are attracted to that too
so why do men like these things
well perhaps the first answer to people
like mallory should be we like it
because we do
piss off we shouldn't have to justify
our sexual attraction to you any more
than you're presumably willing to
justify yours to us
especially when we're simply pursuing
the same things in women that billions
of other men have pursued throughout
history it's all very normal and healthy
one of the big things that makes these
attributes attractive to men
you know hips breasts and so on youth as
well
is that it's a marker of fertility
our attraction to the feminine form is
biological it's a product not a
patriarchy but of evolutionary biology
a feminine woman with the classic sort
of hourglass shape or something close to
it signals health and vitality obesity
signals sickness
obese women also have more problems with
their fertility fertility which again
shows why men don't find it attractive
a man
whether it's in the forefront of his
mind or not
is looking for a woman with whom he can
start a family
that's why the personality traits that
men find most attractive women because
it's not all about looks also there is
also an element of personality there but
all of the personality traits that men
find attractive in women are all of the
ones that will make her a good wife and
mother not the ones that will make her a
good ceo okay not the ones that will
make her successful in business
but the ones that will make her a good
wife and mother is she caring is she is
she compassionate is she affectionate uh
does she have a maternal instinct these
are the things the men are looking for
and that's also why
the most unattractive and repulsive
woman to a man
is an obese feminist
because she lacks literally everything
that a heterosexual man wants everything
which only makes her
more bitter to straight men which only
makes her more repugnant to them by
extension which only increases her
bitterness and it becomes this vicious
cycle
none of this is the fault of men we're
just being who we are
wanting what we want okay
and we don't have to justify that to
anyone least of all malory
because today she is
i'm sorry to say canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavo valdoski our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily dailywire
2022.
today on the ben shapiro show gas prices
spike into unprecedented territory plus
the biden administration reaches out to
venezuela rather than pushing a new
drilling that's today on the bench
bureau shall give it a listen